IT.
WE'RE WATCHING, GOVERNOR.
WE'LL PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION TO
THE MIDTERM ELECTION CHAOS,
SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM IS WITH US.
I'M LITERALLY WATCHING THIS AS
THE WORLD IS, WE GO FROM 57,000,
I'LL READ IT TO YOU, THEN
38,000, THEN 30,000, THEN
21,000, THEN 15,000.
I MEAN, YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
AND --
>> NO, YOU CAN'T.
>> FLORIDA AND FEDERAL LAW IS
VERY CLEAR.
>> THE LAW EXISTS TO AVOID THIS
SITUATION.
YOU WANT TO ACCOUNT FOR THE VOTE
30 MINUTES AFTER THE ELECTION,
EVERY 45 MINUTES.
THERE HAVE BEEN OVER 90,000
VOTES TO COME IN AFTER THE CLOSE
OF VOTING IN CLEAR VIOLATION OF
FLORIDA LAW.
IT'S DESIGNED TO PREVENT THIS
SITUATION.
BROWARD COUNTY IS A NATIONAL
JOKE WHEN IT COMES TO ELECTIONS,
AND HERE'S WHERE KAVANAUGH HAS A
LOT IN COMMON.
WHEN IT COMES TO COUNTING VOTES
AND CONFIRMING JUDGES, THERE IS
NOTHING DEMOCRATS WON'T DO TO
WIN.
THEY TRIED TO DESTROY BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
THEY ARE TRYING TO STEAL THIS
ELECTION, IT'S NOT GOING TO
WORK, AND I CAN'T WAIT TO GET
BACK TO WORK AND MAKE SURE WE
PUT MEN AND WOMEN ON THE
JUDICIARY WHO ACTUALLY FOLLOW
THE LAW.
THE LAW MEANS NOTHING TO LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT OUTCOME, AND THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO -- THEY
DESTROYED CAV KATRINA -- TRIED
TO DESTROY KAVANAUGH AND THEY
AREN'T GOING TO SCREW RICK
SCOTT.
>> SEAN: HILLARY CHEATED BERNIE
SANDERS OUT OF THE NOMINATION.
MARK ELIAS IS HER ATTORNEY.
HE'S THE ONE INVOLVED.
THE MONEY FUNNELED THROUGH A LAW
FIRM.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT WE SHOULD
INVESTIGATE IF THAT'S A CAMPAIGN
FINANCE VIOLATION.
LABELED AS A LEGAL EXPENSE BUT
IT WASN'T.
IT WAS USED TO HIGHER FUSION
GPS.
THIS IS THE SAME MARK.
THAT LEADS TO THE RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
IT'S DISSEMINATED, LEAKED, ITS
CONTENTS, BEFORE THE 2016
ELECTION.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO STEAL
THAT ELECTION BY MISINFORMING
AND PROPAGANDIZING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
SAME PLAYERS, SAME CHARACTERS,
SAME M.O., SAME OBJECTIVE.
WIN BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
>> LOOK AT BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THEY TRIED TO DENY HIM A PLACE
ON THE COURT BY BEING DECEITFUL,
WITHHOLDING INFORMATION FROM THE
COMMITTEE, AMBUSHING HIM,
CHANGING THE LEGAL STANDARDS,
YOU'RE GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN
INNOCENT.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING IN BROWARD
COUNTY?
THEY ARE TAKING FLORIDA LAW AND
TURNING IT UPSIDE-DOWN TO GET A
RESULT.
THIS LIBERAL ACTIVIST LAWYER,
THE CLINTON LAWYER, WENT TO
FLORIDA WITH THE PURPOSE OF
WINNING THE ELECTION.
THE ELECTION WAS HELD ON
TUESDAY.
YOU KNOW, BILL NELSON WAS
RUNNING, NOT THE LAWYER.
RICK SCOTT WON FAIR AND SQUARE.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN BROWARD
COUNTY IS NOT FAIR AND IT'S NOT
SQUARE, AND WE'RE GOING TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
RICK IS GOING TO WIN.
BUT PLEASE REMEMBER THIS ABOUT
2018.
THE 2018 CYCLE IS GOING TO BE
REMEMBERED FOR LIBERAL DEMOCRATS
DOING WHATEVER IT TAKES WHEN IT
COMES TO JUDGES AND VOTES TO
WIN.
THE LAW BE DAMNED, IN THE EYES
OF LIBERAL DEMOCRATS, THE LAW IS
JUST SOMETHING TO GET AROUND
WHEN IT COMES TO WINNING WHAT
YOU WANT.
>> SEAN: REMEMBER A JUDGE FOUND
THAT SNIPES HAD VIOLATED STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW.
THAT WAS THE DEBAR WASSERMAN
SCHULTZ RECOUNT.
SHE JUST DESTROYED THE BALLOTS
ILLEGALLY.
SHE'S NOT UPDATING EVERY 45
MINUTES.
WHICH SHE'S SUPPOSED TO DO.
SHE DIDN'T -- SHE DIDN'T GIVE AN
ACCURATE NUMBER.
30 MINUTES, ALL THE OTHER
COUNTIES IN FLORIDA, INCLUDING
THE PANHANDLE DID.
I JUST -- IF THIS IS NOT
STOPPED, THERE IS NO STOPPING --
THE LEVEL OF CHEATING THAT WILL
GO ON WILL BE UNPRECEDENTED.
>> YEAH.
INCOMPETENT AND DECEITFUL IS NO
WAY TO GO THROUGH LIFE BUT IF